epic games is calling it unreal editor
for fortnite I'm calling it a game
changer because fortnite somehow can
look like this now you could play nearly
any kind of game from racing to an open
world RPG even something that looks
suspiciously like Call of Duty it's hard
to believe that the game can be all this
do all this but it can it's completely
free and it might change everything
let's Dive In
[Music]
if this isn't what you think of when
someone says fortnite I don't blame you
it looks incredible like a fan project
that took years and resulted in a humble
two minutes of footage or something
instead the fans are getting the ability
to make whatever they can dream up in
the game using one of the world's most
popular game engines anything from a
sweeping epic single player experience
to a massive open world is in play now
quite the glow up for the old shooty
building game now the game has been more
than Battle Royale for quite a while the
original fortnite creative launched in
December 2018 and it gave players plenty
of options for creating their own modes
you could build an island set the rules
and then share that experience with
others it was even possible to make some
money through your creator code if
people liked it enough now fortnite
creative definitely expanded what the
game was but these were still clearly
identifiable modes in this bigger game
now this thing used to be called
creative 2.0 but epic is calling it The
unreal editor for fortnite and it's
about to shake things up all over again
epic announced the launch at their panel
state of unreal at GDC 2023 and
seriously just take a look at this and
thanks to Lumen both daytime and night
time look great now let's go to the
final gameplay section and let's close
out the demo
but as a reminder everything that you're
seeing here was created in the same
version of uefn that we're releasing
today if you log into fortnite right now
there are maps mostly curated by epic
that use this technology and look like
the things in that video and the tools
themselves are available right now with
the apparent goal to have all of unreal
engines functionality available in uefn
in one of these Maps Forest Guardian is
just barely recognizable as fortnite the
lighting environment and color palette
seem a lot more at home in a game like
Jedi Fallen order or Sakura even if the
combat is for the moment nowhere close
it was just a short little quest with a
couple of fights but even here you can
see the potential and this thing has
been fully out for just about a week a
game having a map editor say two decades
ago was a big deal I remember killing
tons of hours making maps in brood War
but now fortnite is basically like a
game engine it spans nearly every modern
platform and already has a massive
audience baked into the deal so yeah
when the discussion came up in our
Monday meeting about who would do the
story I was a little bit apprehensive
because
you know outside of the Boomer
retirement home known as no build I
haven't exactly been playing fortnite
consistently all these years on the
other hand I was an absolute fiend for
source mods and those were a bit more
involved to both set up and play than
these so I'm sure it's gonna be fine
right so my plan was just to check out
as much cool [__] as I could and then
see if I can figure out where unreal
will take fortnite lots of popular Maps
continue to be recognizably part of
fortnite of course and might not even
have uefn features enabled yet I spent a
while just shooting around in a Mode
called 10v10 pixel Heroes it let me try
a lot of the weapons that I just had
never touched during my breaks with the
game and also adjust my sense a bit I
also noticed that they had the climbing
system from no build which kind of let
people make some cheeky plays from time
to time it was it was pretty fun that's
actually another good point many of
these modes don't have building enabled
so if that's your specific fortnite hang
up and if it is you might be over the
age of 30 then you're okay because there
are plenty of modes that don't feature
any building at all and if you like
building well there are lots of modes
that are actually focused on it some of
them don't even really include fighting
or even walking around one of the more
popular genres I saw was just infinite
driving maps for example I saw role
playing Maps 1v1 build Arenas and plenty
of stuff that really had nothing to do
with fighting at all I lost an hour last
night playing a fairly robust open world
RPG called Valhalla on fortnite and uh
yeah my Viking has an M1 Garand
apparently so even right now with uefn
just coming out there are plenty of
awesome experiences already in fortnite
now of course there are rules to follow
when making stuff like this and epic has
already had to remind people of them
specifically not to infringe on people's
copyrights so having explained all this
a question arises in my mind why would
someone spend all their time making
fortnite Maps well
epic games is forking over a lot of
money to support this and why are they
doing that well it probably shouldn't be
that surprising if you're a PC Gamer
because you like me probably have 80
something free games on epic game store
that you still haven't played so epic
has been spending money to bring in new
users for a while but this is shockingly
different in that GDC presentation that
I mentioned sax Pearson of Epic Games
mentioned that Island creators directly
resulted in more item shop sales in
fortnite in other words they realize
that the people making content for their
game were making it better and more
interesting for prospective players of
fortnite and epic has decided that they
are going to pay for that and because
you can still look like Leon Kennedy or
a cyber banana or Blanca while you
explore all these islands it's not like
epic games is getting cut out of the
deal like people can still use these
purchases as they explore these islands
so it's really good for epic too the
model that they've implemented which by
the way is retroactive to the beginning
of this month for creators who are
already enrolled is really simple if
people spend time on your map if they
like your map if they favorite your map
and they come back to your map you get
paid for that engagement there's no need
to design cunning monetization Loops or
extractive gating items you make an
island the players love that is all you
need to be part of the new economy now
don't you worry because I'm not going to
sit here and sing epics Praises
uncritically firstly while it's cool and
important that they acknowledge the hard
work that creators put into fortnite
that literally makes the game better it
would have also been cool to not say use
quote privacy invasive default settings
and deceptive interfaces that tricked
fortnite users including teenagers and
children and quote as per the ftc's
press release on over 500 million
dollars in penalties and refunds now
owed by epic and it is after all a
company a company that makes quite a lot
of money so while epic has committed to
giving 40 of their net revenue to this
Creator program we don't really have a
good way of knowing whether that's
actually a fair split based on the
impact that these creators have on
fortnite but let's be real all this [__]
available for free to kids with even the
shittiest PC or even a console and a
monetization model that's just about
people enjoying the content that's a
really nice move from epic I can't deny
it sure there are probably unseen
pitfalls ahead for uefn especially when
we're talking about a game that's as
popular with kids as this one is but if
fortnite truly becomes a platform in the
sense that developers take aim at it or
new developers emerge entirely from it
that's really wild and that is exactly
what epic is trying to do here like
think about it for a sec epic games made
one of the biggest video games in
history and then instead of like moving
on making a sequel or just committing to
a live service type game system they say
no let's take that game and it's massive
audience and change it into something
new part medium part marketplace with
the tools to create so much just freely
available sure you can make some
comparisons to other games out there
like Roblox but I think there's a reason
that developers develop on the Unreal
Engine instead of whatever the hell
Roblox is built on if this bet pays off
epic slice of the gaming pie will get
even bigger you might not have specific
feelings on that but if you're a
fortnite fan that's worth chugging a jug
for
you can hug this person dude
come back here and hug them
why I don't know how they want a hook
I don't know how to hug though
oh my God
such a warm moment
oh the epic music dude jumped out jump
down we gotta help this person they hug
this
this person is my new best friend in
fortnite